zendaya i'm curious for you i mean ryu
gets pretty low this season even though
i'm not sure if she's actually
officially hit rock bottom yet
what was the most difficult aspect of
her journey for you this season was
there a scene or a moment that was most
difficult for you
um i mean it's all
listen it's uh
uh it's all pretty painful uh to be
honest because i care about her
i also care about you know
her future and i care about her life
and her happiness in a way and i think
it's not just because i think
she is
a character that i've grown to love but
i also think she's a representation
of so many
people that are dealing with the same
thing and i think it's it's so important
that we continue to uh or
my my goal
is that you know even when she gets to
those low points you still root for her
and love her
and
and view her in an empathetic
way
uh enough so that you still believe that
there is something
some hope for her that there is a future
for her that she deserves love and
happiness and a beautiful life
even if she doesn't have that feeling um
so it wasn't it wasn't easy in the sense
that you know your mind knows it's not
real but your your body doesn't
you know um
and it's it and it's um
and it's difficult to
be in someone's shoes and do things that
you would never want to say or do to
people that you care about um
it's uh that's when it gets it gets kind
of icky feeling you know because i know
that i have to do it because it's it
belongs her it's rue story it belongs to
her but it as in day i it's not fun you
know
um
but uh
but i think that you know you have to go
to those points
in order to
get to the beautiful parts um hopefully
later later for roo
like she's at her lowest do you feel
like she hits rock bottom this season i
don't want to spoil it you know because
i think that that's part of her journey
you know and that's a decision that she
ultimately has to make for herself and i
think that's part of it is once we get
to that point it's uh is this is this
the end is the change coming what is
going to be the thing
that stops this endless cycle of pain i
think and also realizing i think a
massive thing here too you know major
themes for me are hope
our empathy and redemption and to remind
her we're not the worst thing we've ever
done you know um and that she is still
worth
um
worth a beautiful life you know and i
think it's interesting because
it's difficult
um
because
you you don't know what's coming in the
sense that when i was when we were in
the middle of the season
there was no ending to the season and
i've always kind of been able to get
through the toughest parts of rue
by
reminding myself that rue is an
extension of sam and if sam has been
able to do something beautiful with his
life
um and has been able to move forward and
heal and grow then maybe roo can too but
i never had that
in front of me
guaranteed you know i i i've always kind
of just lived with the hope that that
could happen and i think that
we have to you have to stick with rue in
the hopes that she will get there by the
end of the season and hope is a is a
major factor in this and and seeing that
also that this that addiction is someone
that is something that doesn't just
affect
rue right it it it rains terror on her
family
uh on her loved ones on her relationship
um and it's not something that you know
um
she is the only victim of you know
yeah i mean hunter how difficult was
jules journey for you this season
because jules has some tough decisions
that
need to be made and
are not gonna always have you know a
happy outcome
yeah yeah and i mean i think even before
she um
before she even
can confront those
decisions you have to acknowledge that
she's also operating from
like a uh in like an inaccurate
um
like knowledge of what her partner's
going through uh like
like she doesn't know that uh that uh
you know ruse ruse um
actively
using again and um
and so um
i think if she did it would dramatically
change um
how she how she moved throughout the
season but i also think that's why uh
it's important uh or like elliot's um
presence is important because in a way
he's he's like
a middleman or a um
yeah almost not neutral but um
an independent force between the two
yeah i mean dominick what was that like
for you to join this duo and take on a
character that you know you said you
don't really consider yourself
an actor but you've also said that this
character sort of reminds you of your
younger self but you're also at a point
where you've moved past that so
did it provide like self-reflection for
you to take a journey with a character
like this
absolutely yeah i mean it was crazy
first of all
interrupting this this dynamic this
specific dynamic and then it's kind of
tough watching this kid
make all these dumb decisions and
i mean not out of
malice or anything but you know this is
just how this kid lives and then being
let down and kind of
doing all the wrong things and messing
up i'm pretty familiar with it so
yeah i mean what is it like to play
somebody who sort of can reflect a
different point of your life at the same
time that you've moved past that and can
see that in a different way than you did
when you were in it yourself
i'm actually really happy that i got to
do that because that's all i really know
how to do with music i just talk about
myself the whole time and so i don't
know if i could have especially with my
first time acting i don't know if i
could have just jumped into a completely
different character and just been
someone else every day i'm really glad
that i got to do that
it was a great introduction to this
craft
well without spoilers what is zendaya
and hunter what can you say about where
things will be left with roman jewels by
the end of this season could we do we
have hope for uh you know a season three
for them
oh man
[Music]
this show is listen you just got
out you gotta write out with them and
you gotta remember that they're just
trying to figure it out and they don't
know what they're doing
they are human beings that will make
mistakes and are dealing with a lot of
pain that they don't know how to express
and if you can just hold on to that love
for them hold on to that empathy for
them you know maybe there will be a
hopeful ending and
who knows if that's
with them together or not
but
if you can just hold on
they're just kids yes kids guys
well thank you for talking about it
beautiful work all of you you all broke
my heart this season so thank you
you